véronique sanson je suis contente
aujourd'hui parce que
le niveau du talent et au et la moyenne
d'âge et basse c'est à dire que le gène
d'âge aujourd'hui la mission est de 21 à
peu près vous êtes des visages qu'on n'a
pas beaucoup vu parce que on fait
lentement confiance aux aux jeunes
moi j'aime bien faire confiance tout de
suite
quitte à prendre le risque
et quand je dis prendre le risque c'est
pas un risque mince avec vous puisque
vous m'avez dit que vous ne parliez pas
et comme moi je ne parle pas beaucoup
non plus belles vallées apparence
ne vais ni c'est pas grave on
additionnera nocilla ne s'agit pas un
moment j'ai jamais un mot sur ce
maintenant où je parle peu
même si je vous demande de
ce que vous faites ici par exemple
qui vous êtes pourquoi
qui suit pourquoi
celui-ci on le savait très plaisir de
venir chanter mes chansons glem qui je
suis là je suis une jeune souvent sage
je fais de la musique
et ses paroles et ses musiques
s'ils les chantent
ce qui m'intéresse d'ailleurs c'est que
vous êtes une fille qui comme vous dites
fait ces paroles et sa musique et qui la
chante et qui donne l'impression de
faire ça depuis toujours c'est-à-dire
d'être né avec un pied nous
message panier avec un piano parce que
c'est un peu difficile pour un pauvre
petite maman mais on a mission sur à
côté d'un piano va devant un piano très
très petit
avant vous y avez zhu min on n'a pas du
tout fait faire des gammes qui on a tout
de suite appris à jouer
des choses amusantes c'est mon père qui
m'a appris à jouer du piano il y pas une
note de musique non plus mais il m'a
appris à aimer la musique
levier que l'âge
trois quatre ans
c'était vrai je suis très reconnaissant
de me rappeler ça
mais vous avez commencé à penser à
vraiment chanter
composé en faire votre métier combien de
temps
à en faire mon métier c'est de j'avais
dû toujours lui en faire envie en fait
d'en faire mon métier pour l'unique
raison que je sais absolument rien faire
d'autre que de la musique et
j'ai changé j'ai fait des chansons pour
isabelle de funès ya trois quatre ans je
crois et je suis toujours resté en
contact avec le milieu de la chanson
comme on dit
et
gérants vont enfin j'avais déjà
rencontré michel verge avant dont avec
isabelle
qui lui avait écrit un
concerto pour qui s'appelle puzzle
c'était formidable ça m'a donné à moi
l'idée de d'en écrire un aussi et qui
n'est pas pop proprement dit parce qu'
eelv a dit à électrique [ __ ] concerto
pour deux flûtes de clarinette et
orchestre amusant
et je les écris il ya beaucoup [ __ ]
d'ailleurs et ça m'a pas du tout empêché
de faire des chansons ça explique si
tant est qu'on puisse s'expliquer en
fait on ne peut pas expliquer le charme
mais c'était aux fêtes a surtout
beaucoup de charme c'est très difficile
à situer comme vous dis que c'est pas
forcément pop au sens ce j'avais dit au
sens classique du terme c'est très
original
et ça a surtout
du cher ne peux pas dire si on
si c'est parce qu'on aime la mélodie si
c'est parce que ça
lima do it y un climat général droit
dans tout le disque qui
continuité dans le disque
donc c'est ça oui et il est l impression
de facilité en même temps de doute
c'est pas un problème on a l'impression
qu'on vous n'êtes pas mise devant un
piano disant je vais écrire une chanson
c'est salir le nom les deux sources
ça vient tout seul en fait et le fait
que le disque a été enregistré en direct
dire que j'ai pas chanter sur un
playback
ça a beaucoup
ça a donné une couleur particulière moi
parce que c'est formidable de chanter en
direct hier les musiciens vous stimulez
vous voulez stimuler
et je l'avais jamais fait
j'ai trouvé ça formidable
c'est parce que la limite de
l'improvisation d'ailleurs mais parce
qu'ils peuvent y peuvent eux s'exprimer
beaucoup plus que si ils ont une
partition bien écrite note pour note
devant mener ils peuvent dire des choses
tout le monde est concerné tout le monde
a à dire quelque chose
s'acquitte amusant j'aime beaucoup
chanté en direct
je crois qu'il ya une luge une
particularité sur laquelle il faut non
pas mettre l'accent en fait tout de même
signaler c'est
j'ai employé le terme parce que tout
d'un coup ça devient un terme technique
non pas le vibrato mais la vibration de
la voix et je crois que certains ont
pensé que c'était fabriqués après coup
et c'est à dire en en bougeant
potentiomètre pas du tout oui tu sais
même pas quoi répondre à ça parce que ce
sont des gens qui
ça se voit tellement camp s'il fait ou
potentiellement qu'il faisait pas fait
pendant sûrement oui mais je crois que
le mieux ce n'est pas de répondre ce
soit de ya quand même une promesse
utiliser de nous couper là quand même
une preuve c'est que je vibre toujours
en mesure
déjà que quel que soit le ritz est
toujours dans la mesure du risque arrive
rapide je vibre rapidement et on se
prend tellement une preuve quand même me
faire vite oui c'est ce que j'avais dû
hériter je crois pas qu'on puisse faire
du charme avec un potentiel
mais quand vous dites je sais pas trop
quoi répondre à ça moi j'ai envie de
vous demander de ne pas répondre et 2
j'aimerais vous donner une phrase une
phrase musicale a cappella comme saddam
je vous chanter juste c'est sans danger
par exemple par exemple bahia au début
de
ça me ferait plaisir d'entendre votre
voix sans musique du tout sens en
accompagnement d'accord début de bahia
où le milieu en fin de parole me
souvienne pas lancé le matin on n'ira
pas l'eau de bahia
comme salis bateau j'aimerais bien un
petit peu plus long plus long mais ça
chauffe ça je lisais me tuer
je peux pas le faire plus long la mesure
s'arrête
ah ben je ne vous demandez pas une
performance technique je voulais la
suite de la chanson
d'accord juste vingt trente secondes
s'il vokey
matin on ira voile ou de bahia
il n'ya pas d'ouragan setram aux païens
un jour de pluie ça n'existe par les
jours de pluie ne reviendront pas
moi
ce que c'est agréable d'entendre chanter
juste avec cette décontraction
peut-être
à part ça à part la musique à part la
chanson qui est toujours j'aime bien
rencontrer des gens
j'ai rencontré des gens j'ai pas
d'autres passions que la musique si vous
voulez j'aime pas énormément quelque
chose d'autre
mais si que les gens c'est un beau
programme
en vie et la musique beaucoup de musique
il ya beaucoup de gens du bail à bobigny
chic et d'autres pas ya beaucoup de gens
et en plus la musique c'est une très
jolie manière de les rencontrer
sans parler
merci
[Musique]